family a former President Jimmy Carter
has revealed that his wife former first
lady Rosalind Carter has been diagnosed
with dementia 95 year old Mrs Carter
remains at home with her husband who is
98. the former president began receiving
Hospice Care earlier this year during
and after his presidency Roseland Carter
became one of the country's leading
mental health advocates in a statement
The Carter family noted her lifelong
work writing there are only four kinds
of people in this world those who have
been caregivers those who are currently
caregivers those who will be caregivers
and those who will need caregivers the
universality of caregiving is clear in
our family and we are experiencing the
joy and the challenges of this journey